[Music]
ti9 had it all a slew of upsets an
insane lower bracket run and the
unlikeliest of first ever repeats now if
you want to relive all of the glory that
was ti9 the flashiest plays the sickest
comebacks and the 200 IQ maneuvers our
best of has got you covered but that's
not what this video is about this video
is about the fails funny moments and
gaben knows the memes first up we've got
the most laugh and cringe inducing
nonsense to happen in game and step
those are looking for its own engagement
CT and see who's trying to bring down
set it one spots want to lend aid he
doesn't have a straw or available
however and chaos noise just waiting it
out for the moment boys don't know what
that was all right we've got a little
bit of a crash here's the radio DotA
nobody's dying everybody's running away
from each other they're waiting on each
side of the river
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway placement is but that they might
have an inkling yeah again for anybody
that's wondering you can't get the extra
vision chickens fixing themselves gets
out on top honey rooms
it's like infamous also going to be able
to pick up - yeah so the reason he
brings out the car like that is
guaranteed
changed the career she gets back as fast
possible for the body clock here this
chickens putting in work
that is actually the crowd are watching
the same thing here they are a little
dismayed lay matchup magic let's turn
around Thompson underneath the tower
take a lot of damage some fairy barber
keep in the whoa sprays loser disrespect
she's gonna go back into the tower cuz
of course like this is where you hold my
god recently been it's just me that's
mean man fuels answer Yeol's but it's
not enough another tuna timer this time
it's the shadow demon what are you gonna
do care about the creeps tan they want
to go for this high ground push softness
against dumped on by the beginning you
are either his own fee give me all the
time for the cursor is there he's gonna
serve us Cataclysm at the cataclysm
inside the Curtis rear are they he
absolutely destroys as a team a team is
already exposed ace he throws on a stun
he just dies no buyback we're looking at
the end of the game are they
try to dive the fountain again finger
goes out it's gonna creep and said I am
playing well this game
alright I'm playing I'm pretty [__]
close to perfect I think actually it's
my teammates that are [__] Christ sweet
Jesus holy crap we're never we're never
looking at shadow demon around spiders
it did they all get Oh hallo God sounds
soul catcher here is like cm into that
support category Jade says no bling :
and illusion Oh No and now the BKB cm
with the desk ladies just gonna look -
right clicking no TV oh he's dying in
the black hole gah to go all the damage
ugh he says I'm the carried out [__]
get the kill bear it dear he may be
caught the toss is coming in trying to
save the day by sharts okay that's in
the wrong direction a little odd but
Chris Luck's gonna turn and train by T
but Coco's rhombus well spirit vessel
it's gonna be able to show ball Nate's
videos but I can't keep gaming just
bringing the answer he'll make an impact
he requested some forces up movement
since up here and perhaps can guarantee
this bottom rune will he even get it
though is the question and the coin says
no there's a high-five over the fissure
she's in good spirits you'll have to see
me he'll keep DeeDee
oh yeah sure hits that little tense
who's gonna make up for its build the
triangles
surrounded apps or gets the blink away
up to the high ground powershot lands
the stun and they find yaps or getting
greedy up on top of the cliff really did
he is like we know that spot very well
to can't hide their from us and he's
also just starting to kill not evidence
under sense nobody I'm gonna keep the
distance time with the shackles the
neutral
it's like 1.5 a nice level I still like
a rat's unless you get some sort of
crazy arrow into something nice
absolutely perfect but they're down on
the low ground does he spot them out and
not fight there behind some trees and so
I'll catch you're already out looking
for the follow-up the neutrals to do
they have enough first image to do this
he's got 21
Oh No grab the creeps and veeko baby
blesses the stars and jumps away that's
a freebie
now just because there isn't a chat
wheel in the real world doesn't mean
that there weren't any fails or funny
moments to happen out of gate we have
Team Alliance here at ti9 you did it
exciting stuff indeed I'm more nervous
about this something at the imma be
serious whatever this just happened
Cyrus okay a few moments later
game we have ourselves a batch where
both sides really they had their chance
right
they had their game plan thing you know
with your first eio i say you've been
doing really good man thank you yeah you
as well
yeah thank you I bought my motto
actually is I want to do good just not
too good getting to look at a bracket in
a few seconds here they're getting all
of that ready right now but we were in a
situation where it's like we have a
five-way and I mean we could we could
still have a five-way but it oh you
meant in the bracket yeah yeah so it was
a potential for several teams to get the
exact same score and we were gonna have
to figure out you know which one's gonna
make it to the upper bracket lower
bracket all that stuff Group A initially
had the threat please stop writing of
there being a three-way tie between
Alliance and mineski and TNC can't even
imagine what the players are going
through I actually want to take a look
at cap during that matchup
we'll just like dog there's a little
saying that's cat makes us wet but it
looks like he makes himself wet as well
the chat wheel sounds
matches expectations they go lower
bracket elimination and everything's
clean but I don't want clean
I want it dirty yeah let's talk about
the heroes heroes so what the cam dota 2
[Music]
right right right right
but but that's tomorrow and you know we
are about to say good night but it's not
over for everybody watching you're not
done yet it is time for a late game with
the Kota Imperium flexors
what I bet what we get this crowd really
hyped up is if they got the shirt who
wants the shirt anybody out there
yeah oh thanks everybody hopes thank you
everyone
getting some orders
[Applause]
not experience I know it's safe
[Music]
how's this taste like she's cheap she's
looking to the future like it's not like
these guys are near the end of their
careers you take any of their two
players add their ages together they're
still younger than the hot there's
there's so much time for these guys it's
true
back from mineski briga to be the ones
to take objectives legit even
threatening going into the high ground
yeah they did smoke so that they can sit
behind magic hole he's got this ages and
he's taking this pretty quickly
and the best part about playing cypher
in a game like this cap is you have so
much that can frontline and initiate for
you and if you just look at the way he's
just chomping down this everybody
expected The Alchemist to be taken out
of the pool and I'm not sure if anybody
expected a Thompson tidehunter oh it
seems like oh T's bringing something
different that we haven't seen yet but
yeah I think the idea behind it is how
did you become friends again after time
we first you just go to do yeah happy to
be here and it's cool and then we're
doing this yeah it is really cool what
Wow perfect forms because when we
actually look at this tornament it seems
like we may have a record
all right phonebook right now can we
just keep the camera on well guys that's
it for the most highlight worthy fails
and funny moments from this year's
international be sure to like the video
subscribe to our Channel and let us know
in the comments which casts recall you
think is going to be included in next
year's compendium see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
bring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else
hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]